so when I looked through the syllabus to
this class and thought about what I
could possibly add that would be useful
in addition to the very skills one of
the things I've been thinking about has
been how do you think about yourself as
a founder how do you think about what
the skill set is and what are the things
that you should be thinking about in
terms of am I ready how do I get ready
is it the right thing for me these sorts
of things so let's start with the
perception of what a great founder is
and classically you know this tend to be
Steve Jobs Bill Gates Elon Musk Mark
Zuckerberg Jeff Bezos and it's an image
of founder as superwoman or Superman
right who is has this like panopticon of
skills and I can use the word panopticon
cuz I'm here at Stanford but the it's
things like I know how to do product
market fit I'm great a product I'm great
at strategy I'm great at management I
can fundraise right I can do all of
these different skills and part of what
you're looking for in a great founder in
the kind of theory of the founder as
super person is I'm looking for someone
who is awesome at all these things
they're there they are well-rounded
they're diverse they can bat on all
skills and you know part of how I found
this kind of emphasized in my own the
beginning of my own entrepreneurial
journey as I remember reading an article
that said you know Bill Gates who is
smarter than Einstein right and you're
like well look go Gates is pretty smart
and is very accomplished but I'm not
quite sure smarter than Einstein attacks
rephrase that even bill would want to be
actually next to and it's partially
because I think is this image of founder
as super person which is that a great
founder is someone who can do anything
you know jump over tall in tall
buildings in a single bound you know all
of these sorts of things and the reality
right is a founder as someone who deals
with a ton of different headaches and a
no one is universally super-powered
generally speaking you hope to have a
couple of superpowers some things that
are unique edge to you some
things are unique the problem you're
trying to solve some things that may
help you give an edge because actually
competitive differentiation and
competitive edge is super important but
but it's not it's not actually in fact a
function of of genius and matter of fact
frequently it's very hard to tell the
difference between madness and genius
because usually the result to play out
and sometimes when you're dealing an
uncertain environment you may even the
genius and later be thought to be a mad
person or you may be a mad person and
you turn out to be lucky in your later
thought to be a genius so it's actually
kind of a challenging set of like how do
you think about you know these sets you
know what is the whole set of skills and
when us mere mortals you know come into
this kind of battle what is the way
right way to think about it and so you
know when I thought about this question
of how is one a great founder you know
part of what you get to is oh I'm
actually this is probably the slide that
poor people on this may even a
suboptimal choice for people on video
but it's like these are all skills that
are super important right these are all
things that you say well okay this is
this is really really important to do
and you must in fact actually do this
well and it begins to look like a
superhuman pact and so what I did is I
decided to take a subset of these and
focus on some of the interesting things
to think about what is it that actually
makes a great founder because it's
actually not that you score 10 out of 10
all these you know you'd be the
entrepreneurial Olympiad but you you are
actually is best at all of these things
so let's start with teams so one way to
kind of I think talk about exploding the
kind of the myth of the super founder is
that actually in fact usually it's best
to have two or three people on a team
rather than a solar founder it's not a
solar founders don't actually play out
and they can successfully but most often
two or three people is actually in fact
a much there when I look at these things
as an investor I say you know what is a
good composition of a project and I and
founders that are likely to succeed it's
usually there's two or three of them and
the reasons are because for example
we've already talked about the fact that
there's this very broad set of skills
there's a whole set of question about
how you adapt your company in order to
be successful and if you actually have
two or three founders you have you have
different skills you can compensate
because by the way everyone has
weaknesses you can compensate for each
other's weaknesses you can in the
diversity of problems that you encounter
as a founder that you can actually
attack them so one of the things that I
I suggest when you when you look at
essentially a founding team is to have a
real high preference for having
co-founders having a high degree of
trust for those co-founders because one
of the things by the way part of the
whole entrepreneurial thing is there's
lots of ways to die one of the ways to
die is you get a year down the road with
your co-founders and then you're going
through a messy divorce okay and that's
a that's a that that is a not always but
frequently fatal and so and then also
the diversity of kind of tasks that
you're trying to do it and actually okay
yes I would like to say that will be
suboptimal from a view point of being
able to look at the slide the next thing
is location and so frequently I've heard
told to me it's like Oh Silicon Valley
aggregates all of this super talent
which it does in terms of like what what
actually in fact it's if the reason like
Silicon Valley startups are so
successful is because all of these great
people immigration which is hugely
important for for talent and founders
and health you know emigrate here and
that's part of the reason now it's
actually if you think about it from
basic math even if you take something
that the Silicon Valley is super strong
at which is essentially software skills
in the last two decades not all of the
great software people move here not all
of them can move here there many of them
in various other parts of the world and
and so why do I put choice of location
as one of the things that comes down to
thinking about whether or not your great
founder well the reason is is because
what great founders do is seek the net
works that will be essential to their
problem and their task and they realize
it isn't just about like kind of like I
am super person I can do this anywhere I
can do this you know in you know the
Antarctic etc it's in order to be
successful I have to go to where the
strongest networks are for the
particular kind of problem or the
particular kind of thing I'm doing and
Silicon Valley by the way is super good
at some kind of task some places that
you essentially try to solve certain
kinds of problems but it's not good at
all of them let me take you know kind of
two examples so one is Groupon I don't
think Groupon could have ever been
founded here even though it's a software
product it actually even generates a
network which you know obviously a lot
of the great networks are here and and
uses a kind of Internet technology as a
mobile product and everything else all
of which we have a lot of great skills
here in Silicon Valley and the network's
are really good one of the things that's
central for Groupon for its early days
was having massive sales forces and
massive sales forces strengths and
weaknesses of networks tend to go
together Silicon Valley tends to be
pretty adverse to plans that involve
like oh we're going to rent a 25 story
building and in 20 of those stories
we're going to have floors of
salespeople and that's how we're going
to get our thing going that kind of plan
here tends to not get a lot of interest
tends to get a lot of criticism tends to
not have talent aggregate to it tends to
have finance fears talk about things
like capital efficiency and network
effects and other kinds of things that
are that are key here and so it's
actually not a surprise that actually in
fact Groupon required was required to be
actually in Chicago which is really good
at this as a way of actually kind of
getting going and showing that even
software startups can be in other places
but even if you begin to think about it
you say okay well what kinds of of you
know other kinds of startups would
someone be an idiot to move here to do
think of someone worth doing a fashion
startup not fashion all up parse mark
which is you know a mobile you know
marketplace acceptor which are a bunch
of things are good here but like I'm
designing a new fashion company
and I'm going to come to Silicon Valley
to do it that's actually not such a
great idea right and that hosted the
fashionably might be a great idea but
you want the network's to support what
you're doing and so part of the reason
why where should I locate my startup is
a test for thinking about a migrate
founder is because part of what happens
when you're actually founding a company
is you're going i will go to where it
successful this to do to be because the
metaphor that i prove something use for
entrepreneurship is jumping off a cliff
and assembling airplane on the way down
and the reason is because it's hard
it has a quasi mortal exit while you
which your default dead until you're
taking every possible a chance to
actually win and so great founders go
look i'll move to what the network is
and that network is you know this
graphic is frequently Silicon Valley but
it protects startups for mobile for
networks for marketplaces you know this
is a really good place do it for a bunch
of other things you should think about
whether or not it's a different location
now here's something that you know it's
very in vogue very conventional to say
you're contrarian these days and so
let's talk a little bit about what
contrarian is actually in fact is so
it's actually pretty easy to be
contrarian it's hard to be contrarian
and right and in particular when you're
thinking about is my idea contrarian or
contrarian enough its
how does a smart person actually
disagree with me right is because if you
can't think of a smart person who isn't
like ignorant or just crazy ears enough
but is a smart person who is somewhat
expert in Assen or thinks that your idea
has some serious challenges then it
actually isn't contrarian like so
control and contrarian is also is always
actually there's a lot of things that
Sam and I talked about at startup school
is contrarian is actually relative to an
audience right so when you want to be
when you're when you're thinking about
contrarian in terms of like a really
good contrarian idea it's like okay what
would other states consumer internet
good consumer internet people think is
actually in fact not yet a good idea and
part of when you think about contrarian
is
to say okay what's the way that what do
I know that other people don't know
because it isn't just say oh I'm
brilliant and other people aren't and
that's reason why contrarian thing is
right that's a very bad test might
happen to be true of course lightning
could also strikes in the field but you
know so think a lot about like what is
it that I know that other people don't
know so for example in the very early
days of LinkedIn part of what I advise
all founders to do is go talk to every
smart person will talk to you and give
you feedback so it LinkedIn I walked
around I said here's my idea what do you
think two-thirds or more of my network
including some of the very very smart
people all thought I was nuts and the
reason why I thought it was nuts was
because they said well look at the
network products only valuable with a
bunch of people in it first person no
value and by second person second person
first person it no value for either them
they already know each other when do you
when do you actually begin to deliver on
your use case which is like 500k to a
million people right and so you're never
going to get decide it's never going to
grow now what I knew that the critiques
the critics didn't know was that I could
think of a set of different ways by
which people attend look it's pretty
easy to say look I believe in the vision
of this or I think it's interesting or I
think a product like this exists or I'm
going to play around with it and I can
you leverage those sets of interests to
grow the network to get to enough size
that you could begin to deliver on the
value propositions in which LinkedIn had
and that was the specific thing that I
knew that the critics one thing about
and so when you think about being
contrarian you have to think about how
is it the smart people let's agree with
me they disagree with me from a position
of intelligence I and there's something
that I know that they don't know that
actually in fact will play out to be
true now in this case in general as a as
a founder it's good to be contrarian in
the real sense and like now the other
last part on the contrarian Asst is to
think about there's a lots of different
ways to be contrarian so for example a
frequent one will be like oh yeah that's
a good small idea but actually not
optimal its large or you know actually
in fact you can assemble the talent or
while most consumer internet startups
tend to the electric sample is another
LinkedIn example tend to be only
successful to rocket ships I
a gradual compounding curve can actually
be very very valuable LinkedIn never had
its rocket ship moment it was it was
kind of compound year by year but that
in the consumer internet tends to be a
atypical to the pattern so here you
begin to get to a bunch of sorts of
problems that essentially Sounders run
into which is like well should I be
doing the work or should I be recruiting
people and delegating the work and
classically the answer to this is
actually in fact you need to do both
right and in fact not only do you need
to do both you need to do sometimes one
at 100% and sometimes the other 100% and
sometimes even though this is not so
good at math both at 100% and so what
you'll see is this is actually classic
when you begin thinking about what is a
great founder is you navigate what is
apparent paradoxes so another one that I
frequently talk about is you've got to
be both flexible and persistent and the
reason for this is entrepreneurs are
frequently given the advice to you know
have a vision stay firm against
adversity you know realize that you you
have a vision that is controlling what
other people think and just stay on
track get through the difficult time to
get there the other piece of advice
given with equal vigor is listen to data
listen to customers a pivot be flexible
right part of the thing this comes out
to being in terms of being a great
founder is to say well when should I be
persistent when should I be flexible and
the vehicle that I most often use for
this is you should have on a project
you're doing like a company an
investment thesis that essentially says
why you think possibly contrarian why
you think this is potentially a good
idea it should include what you know
that you think other people don't know
and then as you're going into the battle
field you go is you know am I in fact
increasing confidence in my investment
thesis or decrease in confidence in my
investment thesis because I've found
increasing confidence then hope stay on
track you know be persistent and by the
way sometimes even with adversity your
confidence can increase if it's
decreasing that doesn't mean jump out
PayPal LinkedIn
Airbnb a whole bunch of startups driving
up I've been part of have had months
where you were like oh my god this why
did we ever think this was a good idea
kind of a valley of the shadows moment
example and PayPal was you know August
two thousand we're burning twelve
million dollars in one month the expense
curve was exponentiating we had no
revenue decrease in confidence however
we say okay what do we do in order to
fix that and that gives you your
immediate action plan another one is
should you have belief or should ya fear
right should you have you know could it
should you essentially go well no no I I
have this vision of the way the world
should be and I should ignore everything
else and I should just what that well
again part of what being a great founder
is is being both able to hold the belief
to think about where it is you want to
be doing and why don't want to be going
but also be smart enough that you're
essentially listening to criticism
negative feedback competitive entries
where you kind of go on okay is this
changing my investment thesis is
changing what I'm planning on doing it
doesn't mean lose confidence you have
the confidence but you also essentially
have the peril again in this kind of
thing of how do you put these two things
together should I focus internally build
a product ignore the world ignore
competitors control shows focus
externally
should I be recruiting should I be
meeting people should I be gathering
network intelligent again the answer is
both and the reason why I'm focusing on
these kind of it's is both rather than
either/or is because part of what makes
a great founder is the ability to to be
flexible across these lines to sometimes
be ninety percent one way sometimes be
eighty percent the other way the
executing the judgment on what is the
current problem look like how is it that
what I'm trying to solve this that I
should say this is what we should be
doing and how should I be dividing the
work and part of when you think about
these things as you say like this is
another one is kind of classic as people
say well I'm completely motivated by
data it's what customers said to user
groups you know I've a lot of
entrepreneurial methodologies lean other
kinds of things we talked about is like
gather the data be guided on the data
well actually in fact data only exists
within the frame
of a vision you're building to
hypothesis of where you're moving to and
the data can even be negative and you
can think well actually in fact this
negative data means I need to change or
alter the way that I'm thinking about
something but I actually keep on a
specific vision about what I'm doing and
by the way sometimes even when you have
that specific vision
you don't necessarily actually ever end
up at that big vision that you were
thinking about so for example you know
at PayPal we distributed these t-shirts
that said the new global world currency
right well actually in fact one of the
times I know Peters been here one of the
jokes I told Peter is like well actually
we do have this new world global
currency what we're trading in is
dollars you may have heard of it it's
existed for a while
right we're essentially a master
merchant for that now of course this
message is what might be happening with
Bitcoin although now has the whole love
of topic there however the key thing is
is that vision of saying we are creating
a kind of a universal network that
allows anyone to to pay anyone to become
a merchant to bring the electronics into
the speed of commerce at any business
that is being transacted that vision
kept it true north but we say well first
we think we're going to have a banking
model then we think we're going to have
you know a debt model oh no we're going
to have a master merchant model and how
does that actually play out so you're
always combining the vision and the data
and the data is within the framework of
the vision and sometimes of course what
you learn changes your vision now this
is one of the ones that I actually think
we saved this special picture for one of
the ones that I think is quite key is
that normally entrepreneurs founders are
thought about as having like they're
risk takers right there they're they
worth everyone else cowered in fear from
this notion of risk they boldly go out
now that's true you have to be a risk
taker you have to be thinking about how
I make a really coherent bet on risk
because in fact the only really big
opportunity is the only contrarian
opportunities smart people disagree with
you on happen to be one that have risk
associated with them on the other hand
part of the skill set that
you're beginning to apply how you think
about risks as an entrepreneur is you're
beginning to think about like how do I
take intelligent risk how do I take a
focused risk that if I'm right about
that one thing okay then a bunch of
other things break my way and once I
start doing that I try to figure out how
to make my my on shot possibility as
high as possible
eg how I minimize other risks how do I
essentially take this risk in an
intelligent way that doesn't just go oh
yeah risk risk to the wind who cares but
let's go and so this kind of combines
that you know this image which I think
is the best of the of the of the images
we found for this yet is kind of the
sense of how to think about now back to
what I was saying in terms of having an
investment thesis part of having an
investment thesis is you chart it out
it's kind of a list of bullets you say
like example an early LinkedIn it was
like look everyone is actually going to
be benefited by a public professional
network everyone will realize including
companies that it's better to have it
play out this way the initial set of
adoption will come from essentially
people who like visualize the role this
way or willing to play with it and then
eventually the mass market will come on
as they begin to have a network that
it's already delivering a value
proposition to them that's what kind of
an investment thesis can look like and
then you know you got economics so like
initially recruiting and then and then
broadening other things you have that
investment thesis and you say is my
investment thesis increasing or
decreasing in confidence do I think that
the data that I gets in the market while
I talk to smart people how does that how
does that change my confidence in it and
this is actually how you essentially
minimize risk so for example very early
very early days in PayPal
the part of what happened is they said
oh okay well we're going to do cash on
mobile phones will the cash on palm
products because it's really easy we
have to realize the cash and Palm Pilot
wouldn't work even before we launched
the product because basically what
happened is I went in and said to max
and Peter I said look here's our
challenge our challenge is we're this
room probably remember what Palm Pilots
are they were like early PDAs
and so if we lived in were what was Palm
Pilot Central and the whole use case was
splitting the dinner tab and how many
people at everyone at the table would
have a Palm Pilots budget in a tab zero
to one in every single restaurant so you
could even just by thinking it through
you realize like the direction you're on
is going to hit a minefield and you need
to pivot and that's what Max Levchin
came up with the idea saying actually in
fact we could sync by emails we get
email payments as the backbone of this
we're like ooh that's a good idea and of
course that's what the whole thing kind
of pivoted into and that's part of
thinking through minimizing the risks as
you're actually executing here's another
one's kind of classic which is well
should I have this long-term vision or
should I be solving local near-term
problems and again the answer is both
it's these paradoxes and the question is
if you jump between them you should
always have a long-term vision in mind
because if you actually completely lose
your your directions eventually you'll
find yourself in some field there's not
a good path out of but if you're not
focused on solving the problem at
immediately in front of you your host
right and so part of the question about
how you put these things together is you
say okay short-term what's the thing I
need to be doing today
having made progress today have made
progress this week but is it largely on
path so I'll give you an example of how
this plays out in terms of financing or
term strategy so people frequently think
product strategy is fundamental to how
startups like I have a product idea
that's the thing I'm a founder actually
in fact the next level down on strategy
is usually product distribution whether
it's consumer Internet or or enterprise
or anything else because actually in
fact no matter how good your product is
if it doesn't get to customers you're
hosed so usually you have to have
product distribution is more fundamental
than the actual what the product is and
the one below it is financing and the
reason by financing is if you run out of
money and the whole effort goes away
even if you have a really good idea
doesn't work so frequently when you're
executing on a good strategy you're
actually in fact when I'm raising money
this fund raising I'm thinking about the
next fundraising I'm thinking about how
I'm set up for it I'm establishing
relationships that would be key to that
and I'm I'm not executing like oh the
only thing
matters is I get to the next is get to
the next fundraiser because you have
this business that you're building but
I'm thinking that is the core strategy
in terms of how I'm executing and
frequently you're thinking about okay
how does my product distribution work
such that the financing works well and
that's kind of how you architect these
things together so how do you know if
you might be a great founder well it's
you should have some super powers it's
generally speaking on software useful to
be a good product person it's useful to
have good skills about kind of
leadership of bringing networks in of
persuading people and it's useful to be
able to and this is kind of the most
fundamental is recognized whether or not
you're on track or not to have both that
belief but also paranoia about am i
tracking against my investment thesis
and when you do that the right way and
you're learning and you're assembling
people and you're assembling networks
around you that's generally speaking how
you end up being a great founder now
classically and I deliberately put up
five white men mail pictures is
classically you have a kind of a these
are the ICONic founders but in fact
founders can be very diverse they can be
extraordinarily talented at different
areas because there's different kinds of
entrepreneurial companies there's
different kinds of problems they're
trying to solve and I don't just mean
diversity in terms of classic you know
kind of gender race etcetera diversity
and age diversity and experience you
know jack ball was a was a teacher
before he got into that that's the kind
of thing that you can that you should
think about and so the the question is
is how you cross uneven ground how you
assemble networks around you how you get
people to assemble this is a constantly
changing problem to face when you are
trying the sounded company and so I
think the thing that I was trying to get
people to think about with this is to
say there's not one skill set there's an
ability to learn and adapt an ability to
constantly have a vision is driving you
but to be taking input from all
sources and then to be creating networks
around you and that's essentially what
makes a great founder and you were
ability to do that while crossing uneven
ground in a fog which is kind of the the
way that entrepreneurs you don't really
know but you always know this is gonna
work no unless you're crazy right
although sometimes crazy works so with
that I will now go to a few questions
but it was kind of this mindset a
founder is which is kind of key and if
there's no pressure okay okay how many
things how you started early are the
life is different aesthetics for getting
the right early adopter that you knew
with expecting your investment pieces
really help it
takeoff engine the every third of pages
that ships that same challenge so one of
the really fundamental things is to is
to think about product distribution as
key and for LinkedIn we had a couple
things going for us so one the web was
boring in 2003 that basically what
happened is everyone I thought the
consumer net was over and so people were
renewing clean tech and enterprise
software and everything else there's a
much harder problem now because everyone
thinks the Internet and mobile is
interesting and so breaking through the
noise is really key so the strategy we
use would work we just actually set up
send out some invitations to group
people and then tune the mechanism to
have and did PR to get people like one
of the decisions we made early that was
right was to say should we only allow it
as invite only or should we allow cold
sign ups the reason we should allow cold
signups is because the people who are
super enthusiastic about this weren't
necessarily the people we know so they
would sign up and spread it that sort of
thing where all the kind of decisions we
made now that challenge is much harder
because the challenge when you think
about product distribution is is how are
you competing for potential customers or
potential members time and what do they
think what do they have to believe in
back in 2003 was like well a
professional network that's potentially
a good idea what the hell I'll play with
it there's not a lot of other things for
me to look at today there's tons of
things and so your strategy day when
you're looking a product distribution
has to be what is my really decisive
edge what is the hack that I know that
other people don't know so
thank you
how many killed you know he put on da
bomb just like a carton our chief so how
do I know someone's a good founder or
not well it's not I'm a huge believer in
references usually I only ever actually
know a hundred seven times in this case
I only meet with someone when they come
to me through a reference so one of the
things by the way is that thing is I
after this I have to run off because I
have a meeting I need to get to if you
want to actually get time and attention
we find a reference it's not a pitch to
using LinkedIn it's a question of this
is how you sort out ton you can find out
like Sam knows me
let the throat Sam onto the bus all
right yeah
and so a reference to me is in fact the
way that I do this and so for example
what I meant with the Airbnb guys part
of the reason why I could interrupt them
two minutes into the pitch and say I'm
going to make you an offer to invest I
want to hear the rest of the pitch
because I think what you're doing here
is is magical and awesome was because
I'd already had references on them like
that was only two minutes not even 30
minutes because I already knew about
them before coming in and by the way by
and large that some version out is true
of most of the great investors and it's
that it's that network that's really key
I think it was a question over here to
here it's costing or we are sensitive
insight is a strong signal for great
honest can you say another sentence so
being still pieces out of all right off
Nils down three concise well I would
definitely say that the ability to say
coherently what you're targeting and to
articulate something that isn't trying
to boil the ocean or a Swiss Army knife
approach but is like one focus like what
people write about this and it works
that is actually pretty important to big
to being able to judge the founder
because if you don't have that level of
clarity you're not going to be able to
assemble the network behind you you're
not gonna be able to get investors not
going to get employees you have to be
able to articulate a very clear mission
about what you're doing and insight is
helpful although a little bit of this
depends on
the stage it is always if I find I find
myself attracted to founders who to
analyze the problem a good way but but
frequently I've seen great founders who
do not present good analysis but have an
instinct about what they're doing and
see you more chart will tell what's
going on around them when they can head
like five years of life out again wrap
up guys like what would your going be
like keep like a link Donnell be
original oh why how do I keep
persistence when because actually
LinkedIn went through you know let's see
for those who remember we were we were
treated as the is a is the is a little
alternative to French sir then to
myspace been to Facebook right so we had
a lot of different like we are the
little teeny one next to these two these
respective giants each of the time
ultimately for me when I was thing about
LinkedIn this gets back to the
investment thesis as a mechanism I
continued to believe the action fact the
right economic system design for every
individuals life and for organizations
lives have public professional profiles
but that that that world is the way the
world should be everyone's much better
off with it and we are getting closer to
that than everyone else it may be that
it hasn't taken off as fast as I like it
may be that the general world is going
oh the social stuff is really interested
in we don't like we can only get in the
news in the fall in the summer of 2003
by saying we were friends sure but for
business which is completely collect
nonsensical once you begin on you're
going to look at the thing but it's like
okay we'll cover you because it's
friendship but for business and that was
important to begin to get people to pay
attention to us and so the confidence
was that world I still have confidence
believe that it should exist and no one
is getting closer to it than we it's
taking us maybe longer than I hope to
get there but that's okay
so okay when you do it wrong what do you
use how do you think is going to be
really good and you know it seems to be
able to move between these opposing
forces yep and on paper seems like
they're going to go at it
what is it makes you get wrong about on
that looks good for contribution well to
some degree you can only fully cross
these kind of minefields back to going
and doing it so you're going to be wrong
about your hypothesis the kinds of
things that frequently get you wrong
get get wrong or when you think that a
person because they like for example one
of the tests that I forget to use an
interaction is I push on the idea some
and what I'm looking for is both
flexibility and persistence I'm looking
for know I have conviction and what I
thinking and I'm arguing it but I'm
listening to what you're saying and I'm
adapting to the concerns and whatnot of
how you think about that sometimes
you'll find someone who says look I've
learned to mimic that behavior so I've
learned to say for example I learned to
look look like I'm reasoning with you
and I look like I'm I'm thinking about
the challenge you bring up but actually
in fact I'm ignoring you and ignoring me
that might be fine
ignoring the world in general is usually
disaster and so those are the kinds of
things that in the measurement you can
see essentially getting wrong but but
usually the kind of thing like most
often the kind of reference questions I
ask founders is like adaptability like
one of the phrases that I frequently
look for infinite learning curve because
each entrepreneurial pattern is to
something very unique and new and can
you learn the new one right is way of
doing it and so like does the learning
break down or there's some major skill
set is there an ego issue that gets in
the way like well I must be the grit
like everyone everyone must adulate me
and that will cause you to behave
wrongly in adapting with the problem
those kind of things I think I have one
last question the woman under that key
and the most effective will make sure
that partnership and you're evaluating
heavy a great co-founder co-founding
team how to evaluate and how to think
about co-founders so the first thing is
it's super important that you
collaborate really well that was the
kind of the point I was making during
the team the the initial part of it
because if you in fact don't have pretty
good serious trust
you know kind of a way of of it's 150
I'm so tanned right Oh - ha no no I'll
keep going sorry I misread the time so I
I will have time for more questions
sorry I was trying to be very good be on
so okay let me give a little bit longer
answer to the steps so the key thing is
when you're thinking about founders
founders that founders is do you have a
diversity of the necessary strength to
cross the whole range of strengths that
would be useful frequently you need one
technical founder at least frequently
you need to have someone who is who is
going to be dedicated to the business
side fundraising these sorts of things
that kind of classically skillset when
you think about the two to three and
usually it cuts some composition across
them and that's kind of like what you
think of its founders one when you're
thinking about a founding team when you
when you get the next level deep for
example one of the things that people
will classify to tell you is like people
don't invest in a husband-and-wife team
and actually that look that adds a
little extra Freight to it and
everything else does you know the
personal dynamics also upset what's
going on
I actually think of what you're looking
for is do they collaborate well do they
help each other get to truth right so
for example I am most heartened what I'm
talking to a team that when they're when
they're reasoning to each other they're
not like oh we're just all singing from
the same things that go but did you
think about this or what about this is a
challenge but you're navigating the
field of battle which has a bunch of
risks like for example one of the things
that was pretty common in PayPal is Max
who who invented the fraud systems and
everything else would frequently come
into Peter's office Peter seal Max
Levchin and say look here are some
things they're going to kill us and let
me focus you on them okay so it's not
like we're all just kind of saying all
yes we're all singing our Kumbaya but we
are adjusting to what is truth and
what's the problem we solve what's the
problem the short term what's the
problem in a long term and how we
tackling it and that composition with
their team that collective problem
solving that collective learning is the
kind of thing that actually usually
makes great teams
thank you for Reforma collection I
didn't call you to justice
we actually multiplied hops that we end
up wonderfully trained to do I actually
know how to verify to be Palestine given
the status table my vision help me in
here and is among the public comment
reviewing or heartful assigned for the
vision to mark whether come here today
in colleges or any stuff different
founders different areas how do you
identify them so the talk was aimed at
kind of what is unique about the mindset
I think of founders that is great
sounder across all all founders that's
that part of what this was attempting to
say look because there are differences
so for example in software speed to
market speeds to learning is really key
in hardware if you screw it up you're
dead right so accuracy really matters
right because if you if you build and
ship the wrong thing you're hosed so
generally speaking is an investor and
this is part of the reason why a lot of
investors you know have a certain set of
things that they then learn pretty well
and try to reapply to they try to
understand a domain well enough to be
able to identify which of the founders
in this domain that really matter and if
we're investing in this domain how do we
do that well and so there are attributes
that are unique per domain so for
example you know like like if but one of
the classic ones is how good must you be
at operational efficiencies in terms of
margins cost controls etc you're dealing
in the world of atoms including even in
commerce you've got to be really good at
that you're doing a digital gaming like
a like a single extra up doesn't matter
all right so and and so you look for
that kind of fits and proclivities and
part of the beginning of this is it's
not actually in fact that it's one
person who's good at everything I would
be like one of the funniest
conversations I had with with with a guy
a friend of mine who works for me I
first start up social net if he looks at
me and he said lead I would never hire
you to be a manager of McDonald's oh my
god wouldn't either
terrible at that right and so it's the
skill set that fits but also the whole
point of this is actually navigating a
set of things that look like paradoxes
sometimes being heavy on one sometimes
heavy on the other and being having a
right judgment at the moment in terms of
what you're doing and that's what comes
to be more Universal like you think a
little bit about how new whether I stand
or we top do it you know companies
acting like you're evil so the question
is basically how do you know when to
pivot
part of the reason why having investment
thesis and your confidence and rest in
pieces and being pretty clear on that is
generally speaking the answer that I
give people is if your confidence is
unmeasured for a fairly long time or is
decreasing because unmeasured for a very
long time should be decreasing and it's
decreasing and then you go into intense
mode where you're trying to figure out
what kinds of things you would do that
would increase your confidence right and
that's failing that's a seriously good
time to think about pivoting right and
and you might have a theses on can we
raise money you might have pcs on will
what's the pattern by which the product
distribution are growth or you know
viral imitation or SEO or anything else
will work and it's like well I tried
these three things and the fourth thing
doesn't seem as good as these three and
the next two things that I think about
he we've been worse that begins to
decrease your confidence and that's when
you sing about pivoting a frequent
mistake when it comes to pivoting is
wait until you've essentially that
crashed into the wall and everything is
dead and you can't make any you can't
maneuver anymore and that's that's you
waited way too loud now now in terms of
personal career goals and so forth you
know part of the thing that I would say
that is one of the things that I'd meant
to talk to you during the slides that
since I've misread the time I I rushed
through it a little bit
one of the classic questions is balance
and I actually think founders have no
balance but one of the funniest
conversations I ever had was with the
governor of Colorado it was like we're
going to attract really great
entrepreneurs here because we have this
balanced lifestyle like like literally
if I ever hear a founder talking about
oh this is how I have a balanced life
and to where they're not committed to
winning right and so the only really
great founders are like I am going to
literally pour everything into doing
this now it only may be for a couple
years I may do this for a while and go
to walking but while I'm doing this I am
unbalanced at this thing
it's obviously you don't take breaks not
to say you don't you know go on dates or
whatever else but you're super focused
on this because it's really hard and
there's lots of ways to die that's
reason why the jumping off the cliff
metaphor is one of the ones I
classically use so just ends up give you
like the define on certain opportunities
with others illness 30p overall how
efficient do you think these stars
ecosystem is that identifying okay so
how good is the startup ecosystem and
identifying contrarian opportunities
let's see just kind of challenge because
the moment it kind of actually becomes
in vogue it's less contrarian I think
mixed sometimes because part of what
makes a great investor is an ability to
go look I take this radical shot I take
this radical top shot I take this
radical shot and there's enough people
or investors there's usually someone if
you can find your way to them Network
finding a way through Network sometimes
difficult some tons of noise hard to get
the signal on the other hand is
sometimes things that are just kind of
like you know totally crazy like one of
the funny things is you know a benchmark
was the only one that would fund eBay
you know if you talk to most of the
people in the valley a year 18 months
ago that Bitcoin they would have told
you like what bit what do I have no idea
what it is and by the way still unclear
how Bitcoin will play out although I
think the fact that there will be a
distributed trust system on
cryptocurrency is I think almost
certainly going to exist in the world
and the real question is
is Bitcoin the first or last
cryptocurrency first is the ones the new
features last because it's a lot has
network section is already going and so
I think it's pretty good with it
frequently what happens is people think
they're contrarian because they're doing
something they think is in a unique stop
unique combination I'll give you two
examples and hopefully the founders of
these people who sent me these cool I
get about 30 pitches symphony a day but
I don't basically don't look at and
let's referral unless something in the
title makes me laugh in which case I
look at it mostly is comedy and I'll
share to comedy one one of them was
wearable diapers which was the you know
you have the computer monitoring you
know whether or not the kid is you know
taking a pee or poop and they let you
know and you're like if you're that far
away from your child and this kind of
thing is probably a bad sign of other
things and then the other one was kind
of customized ecommerce bongs you're
like oh I got a contrarian idea yes you
do but not the highway right so anyway
so you know you bet so I think generally
speaking the system is pretty good at it
in the back that ahead of time I'm good
how do you think most creative market
Berkeley creating market versus covering
them yeah so this is actually it's a
challenging question the the freaking
like visit and it's a good follow on the
contrarian thing like frequently there's
this classic thing of oh does the market
exist yet is that because it's going to
be huge or non-existent the good news is
it's usually one or the other right and
so that means going after something that
most people don't think is a market but
you have a reason to believe it is
actually sometimes frequently a good bet
however it can sometimes completely
flame out one of the things you're doing
when you're testing your investment
thesis is what would lead me to think
whether or not there's a market there or
not because you know at the beginning
nor no market and so the it is of course
conceptually possible to create markets
people think that there's a new need for
this sort of thing on the other hand the
problem is is how do you get fast
adoption if people don't even know that
they wanted as a category
right so they say well but people they
just realize like a classic
entrepreneurial misfire a classic one is
if people just realize once it exists
they'll realize that they really love it
and the vault but line up and droves for
it well there's a few entrepreneurs
Steve Jobs one of them who can do that
most the time it doesn't work out that
way and so you have to say what in your
investment thesis why is it that you
think when you're thinking about a
market that isn't already existent that
you know that other people don't know on
the contrarian basis that leads you to
think that market should exist right and
so for example a micro one with LinkedIn
was action in fact Declassified means of
recruiting was in fact an exercise of
newspapers and exercise of information
age and actually recruiting direct to
people it's part of what the networked
age and the Internet and that's actually
in fact how recruiting should go now it
was relatively easy to validate that but
you know that's the kind of thing where
you think about this potentially new
market yeah last question when do you go
home long enough so accommodation want
to think for example when you got the
PayPal link for example how long do you
use it was a lot group of people so how
do you know okay I trust these people
enough to stumble so to reach up I'm
repeating the question in part because
rates as recorded in everything else
make sure that people hear it but the
question is basically is how do you know
that you trust them on well enough to be
a co-founder there's a whole bunch of
different variables to go into it and
look there's one of the risks that you
take and you kind of get to a thesis of
do I think that I know them well enough
now I'll parallel one thing that I think
there's a parallel here that I think is
super useful so one of the things I tell
my portfolio company CEOs or founders
when they're thinking about hiring a CEO
is I think that the only way to do this
is when you get down to the people that
you're thinking you may hire the CEO you
spend 20 plus hours with them right
where you go into as much depth in a
conversation about anything you think as
a possible difference of opinion belief
work style so you've identified all
this upfront so that your your your jet
it's not that you have a contract it's
not like oh we're signing a contract
this is how we do it but we've
established the conversation we've we've
gone to all the parameters we've had a
conversion about what we might agree
with the disagreement one of the things
that I frequently think is worth
covering is almost like kind of a
divorce like why would we want a divorce
what would lead me to say this isn't
working right and to cover that upfront
as part of it because then at that point
when you get into the field of battle
which is hugely stressful you go through
valley shadow and lemon you've at least
got the basis that we already conversed
about a wide variety of things we set up
essentially some expectations about what
you know how we might be playing
together and if it begins they're very
off that it's relatively easy to bring
it up in a way that you're
problem-solving and that's the kind of
thing I think you frequently you should
be fairly confident that you have that
level of trust for me frequently it's to
have a set of robust conversations
that's but I was like like if something
comes up laters like what we talked
about this inversion we can we can bring
that up so anyway with that thank you
[Applause]